>> FARTHER SOUTH, THERE ARE NO
SOUTH SCIENCE OF RUSSIA'S
RELENTLESS ATTACKS ON THE CITY
OF MYKOLAIV.
THE MAYOR SAYS THE CITY TOOK A
POUNDING AGAIN WEDNESDAY
MORNING, THIS TIME HE SAYS THAT
RUSSIA LAUNCHED AIR STRIKES
WHICH DESTROYED THE
SUPERMARKET.
AND CAUSED A FIRE ELSEWHERE IN
THE CITY.
MYKOLAIV IS A STRATEGICALLY
IMPORTANT CITY NEAR THE FRONT
LINES IN THE SOUTH.
AND IT STRUCK ALMOST EVERY
SINGLE NIGHT FOR THE LAST
MONTH.
UKRAINE ALSO SAYS ITS FORCES
ARE MAKING SLOW, BUT SAID THE
PROCESS IN THE SOUTH.
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS SAY THAT
RUSSIAN TROOPS HAVE BEEN PUSHED
OUT OF SOME VILLAGES, AND
STRATEGIC POINTS IN THE REGION.
BUT AS NICK ROBERTSON FINDS OUT,
THE PEOPLE WHO USED TO LIVE
THERE ARE NOT COMING BACK YET.
>> [NOISE] THE ROAD TO --
ISN'T SAFE.
PLAYBOY, HIS WAR NAME, IS
TAKING US THERE ACROSS COUNTRY.
HE SAYS HIS FORCES RECAPTURED
IT FROM THE RUSSIANS FOLLOWING
A TWO-WEEK ARTILLERY BATTLE.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
>> THAT WAS A MONTH AGO.
IT IS STILL DESERTED, ONLY
ABANDONED PETS AND FARMYARD
ANIMALS HERE NOW.
>> WHEN YOU COME IN HERE AND
YOU LOOK AT THE FARM HERE, THE
ANIMALS LEFT OUT, THE DOG IN A
TERRIBLE STATE.
HOW DO YOU FEEL?
>> I FEEL QUITE SAD.
>> AND WHEN CAN PEOPLE COME
BACK TO THIS VILLAGE?
>> I THINK WHEN WE WILL GO
FURTHER FORWARD.
>> FURTHER TO THE NEXT LINE OF
VILLAGERS.
>> UNEXPLODED SHELLS LATER THE
GROUND, THE END OF WAR A LONG
WAYS OFF, HE SAYS.
>> I THINK IT'S NOT REAL
FINISHED VERY FAST BECAUSE WE
ARE NOT SO ON THERE RIGHT NOW.
>> DURING THE ATTACK, UKRAINIAN
FORCES ESTIMATE THEY KILLED
ABOUT 50 RUSSIAN SOLDIERS.
INJURED ABOUT 100 MORE.
THE BIG CHALLENGE FOR THE
UKRAINIANS NOW, MUSTERING
ENOUGH MAN TO ADVANCE FURTHER.
THE FRONTLINE IS JUST A FEW
KILOMETERS AWAY, A SINGLE
ARTILLERY SHELL HITS ITS
TARGET.
THE TROOPS THAT TOOK THIS PLACE
LAST MONTH, HAVE MOVED ON.
>> WE ARE PLANNING TO MOVE
FORWARD.
SHORTLY.
>> WHEN?
>> [LAUGHS]
I DON'T KNOW.
FROM MY OWN OPINION, I THINK IN
A MONTH.
>> AT THE VILLAGE SCHOOL, WITH
THE SMASHED, CROSS ROOMS
TRASHED.
EMPTY BAGS ON THE FLOOR.
AND THE MESSAGE SCRAWLED BEFORE
THEY WERE TREATED.
THE RUSSIAN TROOPS HAVE LEFT A
PARTING MESSAGE, IT SAYS RUSSIA
IS EVERYWHERE!
IT HAS NO BORDERS.
AND OVER HERE, THEY HAVE
CROSSED OUT THE UKRAINIAN WORLD
FOR MARCH, AND SAID USE THE
RIGHT LANGUAGE.
WHEN RUSHERS A PEER TO FIGHT
HARDER IN TRENCHES AROUND THE
VILLAGE.
TANKS TAKEN UP BY ARTILLERY.
YOU GET AN IDEA OF THE FEROCITY
OF THE FIGHT HERE FROM THE
ARTILLERY IMPACTS, AND THE WAY
THAT THE TREES AROUND HERE ARE
ALL SHREDDED.
BUT HERE IS A SURPRISE.
HITTING THESE TARGETS WITH U.
S. GIFTED ARTILLERY WAS NOT AS
EASY AS THE SOLDIERS EXPECTED.
>> IT SHOOTS QUITE GOOD.
BUT, NOT SO GOOD AS WE
EXPECTED.
>> NOT UNGRATEFUL, HE SAYS.
AND VERY WILLING TO LEARN VERY
BETTER SKILLS.
NIC ROBERTSON, CNN, UKRAINE.
>> UKRAINE OFFICIALS ARE
DISMISSING SUGGESTIONS BY
FORMER GERMAN CHANCELLOR THAT
MOSCOW WANTS A NEGOTIATED
SOLUTION TO THE WAR IN UKRAINE.
FORMER CHANCELLOR MADE THEIR
MARK ON WEDNESDAY, AFTER
MEETING LAST WEEK IN MOSCOW
WITH THE RUSSIAN LEADER.
HE CITED THE RECENT RAIN DEAL
AS POSSIBLE STARTING POINT
TOWARDS A CEASE-FIRE, BUT
SCHROEDER HAS HAD MOST TIES TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN FOR MANY YEARS,
AND HIS COMMENTS DID NOT SIT
WELL IN KYIV, TAKE A LISTEN.
>> [INTERPRETER]
IT IS SIMPLY DISGUSTING ONE
FORMER LEADERS OF MAJOR STATES
WITH EUROPEAN VALUES WORK FOR
RUSSIA, WHICH IS AT WAR AGAINST
THESE VALUES.
[END OF TRANSLATION]
>> UKRAINE'S FOREIGN MINISTER
SAYS MOSCOW REMAINS FOCUSED ON
ITS MILITARY OBJECTIVES IN
UKRAINE AND THAT EVERYTHING
ELSE IS A SMOKESCREEN.